okay so I haven't been able to make any
sense of this show whatsoever em right
now we're on the sewed three prisoners
of love so I've decided to bring in
someone to help me hi Brad
hi so this is your first adventure time
episode am i right first time seeing it
all the way through yes yes and what
symbolic meanings came alive to you
watching this incredible experience
right I won't like that kind of a lack
of sleep I'm not even convinced that
actually happened yes cuz I know you
haven't gotten much sleep
probably though you just showed me a
blank screen you're gonna convince me
that what I just saw actually it
happened but if you could say what
actually happened that there was some
importance and meaning to your life i
well i sat there during the opening
credits like where like I'm sitting like
whoa whoa whoa slow down slow down where
the ice mountain's word the forest word
the doser you're like it's time just
going and fast motion has no intro it
doesn't say like well this is Ben this
is Jade these are their adventures this
is where that none of that you pretty
much starts like this episode that
you've just seen and this is the entire
there's nothing you need to see
beforehand that explains anything really
so like some random stuff just kind of
happens like how this particular episode
he the dumb Jake the dog just turns off
apparently he can do that it has never
been clarified or anything like that's
that's what I was having problems keep
it's not the only problems keeping up
one of them was like that was the only
thing that confused me um was like I got
to you it was like is it established
that he could do this because all the
sudden he's like the size of Clifford
and his hand turns into a key yes and he
just sort of does that has never
explained the only other character we
seen before this because there's a bunch
of princesses and yeah
phrasing and the lumpy Space Princess
which you're like
LSP I'm like lumpy Space Princess that's
like the only carryover from any of the
other episodes everything else it's like
ya know knowing that no ties it all
together an evil wizard white beard
wasn't in there no or hand my first
appearance there well they got to
establish the villain at some point I
guess this is pretty much just help me
out with this because you like Rena see
we both like yeah I grew up like yeah
but I grew up with it as you know kid
you know enjoying it does I mean I
certainly had the animation style of
something you would see in like early
90s Nickelodeon and I have friends who
have really similar tastes in humor as
me really liked this show so maybe like
I don't maybe some episodes really like
I seem to know of an episode that
directly references of all things so I
like but sitting there just watching
that one episode I'm just going off of
that like I don't know maybe some other
episodes are like pretty funny really I
didn't even think that was that bad
because I I do kind of like random humor
it's so random I mean it is it is very
very random but for me the difference
between random and just straight-up so
real cuz when you get into like just
surreal territory that's when it starts
that's when stuff starts to lose it like
something like Superjail where it's like
not even the most powerful drug in the
world could get me interested in this
like it's just people screaming at each
other and hacking each other up with
like oh there's like no story or no yeah
like at least this the humor is all
random it's a ring like he's suddenly
he's got a key on his hand suddenly he's
big suddenly there's like hot dog
princess yeah but if you actually there
is a semblance of a story that's going
on yeah it is constantly breaking from
the store
from the characters and that's the humor
comes from its but it's one of those
things where it's like when you watch it
cuz I mean I remember I was talking
about like this show it hurts me you're
like oh it's that bad I'm like not
necessarily yeah yeah like I can't say
it's bad but I don't I can't describe it
and it's one of those few shows where
because but even that we're sitting
you're talking about where if it's just
so real no story or anything abhi
Oh arty-farty
whatever you know but even then not even
that I think stuff like that is
necessary not all of it something like
Superjail it's not that I'd necessarily
think it's artsy I just think it's
designed for people who are on some
powerful and I can't make heads or
tails of anything on that on that
particular show but at least this at
least this yeah the humor is certainly
out of left field it's very random you
don't know what's gonna happen but there
is a point a and a point B in terms of
the story that was going on it was there
abducted by the Ice King or whatever and
then they go into a prison cell which
honestly they really could squeeze you
through the bars but that really should
have been their planet they there's like
strawberry princess hot dog princess
which I kind of got a kick out of I
liked what they were all the inspiration
he wants this because he wants to marry
all of them so he's kidnapping them and
hoping it gets all try to figure out
which one he wants I want to know which
one I want I'm gonna keep him in the
cellar and pray to god they come down
with Stockholm Syndrome cuz marriage is
like a very delicate thing like I seen
this storyline and it's usually not in a
children's
actually like in a psychotic skin it's
usually it like something like a Jack
ketch of movie or something like that
not like it's usually the stuff that
gives me nightmares not like oh yeah the
kids will enjoy this I kept saying like
this is like if someone got really high
and forgot they were babysitting someone
and the kid was like tell me a story and
this is the story they would tell well
there was a dog and a kid his arms moved
like mr. fantastic they're on a snowy
mountain don't ask why their sled gets
broke I don't know dog turns big he
rides up the dog as well I wasn't sure
by the way just it was come down to
Springfield sometimes you'll sledding on
like a the chairs not straight I broke
my tailbone
well yeah you broke your tailbone you're
sledding on saran wrap what do you think
is gonna happen so now that you've seen
this show that has a huge following
anyway we've gone the cons we see like
tons of people dressed up like these
characters you know the white yeah I
still don't know what that hat is I
don't know if that's like a bear or a
rabbit or what but yeah I mean do you
look at this oh I get it or what the
hell is going on what's your impressions
of this show it's when I chuckled like
once in this episode but it appears to
have the same kind no maybe not as I
really am just going by this and some
stuff that I've heard but it seems to
have very much a similar kind of random
humor to it that that you wouldn't see
on something like Ren & Stimpy although
Ren and Stimpy kind of anything Ren
Stimpy might have been done more over
the top that has managed to be was
certainly cheerfully over the top France
to me would usually sort of stay in one
spot do you know like in terms of like a
story and it's like this kind of does
but like it'll just it was always so
even to us out of maybe another
character
this always has like five or six or
eight characters yeah going on there
constant doing weird things and saying
we do things and there's just there's
like very rarely abnormal moment didn't
wear rims didn't be by the joke could be
they could just sit and look at
something for like a minute yeah you
know and nothing would happen because it
was that strange so I mean I don't know
I'm just trying I'm just trying to
figure out what the hell to talk about
these video logs because I just every
episode is like this out just like how
do I analyze this how do I talk about
this that I don't know if it's like dude
am I totally failing at this like erased
there just really nothing to talk about
or it's like I because it's such a huge
hit I like analyzing what makes some
things a big hit like why is it catching
out with some people but it's a lot like
oh my god I was stoned right now I would
love this my friends who are big fans of
that of this show yeah oh my god if I
was high as a guy this would be like my
heaven right now
yeah because pouring on the floor with
laughter random humor can be really
really funny and I can kind of like if
there was a couple jokes in there yeah
like they've been worked on me the
random humor can be I like kind of
random stuff because like because okay
in this let's say the part where okay
the part where the hot dog princess is
just playing Easter bananas fan by by
herself that's that's random certainly
like you can't predict that something
like that's gonna happen
unless your weed is so powerful you see
in the future you can actually predict
this yeah yeah I think the writers of
this show could predict it like so but
but but with it being so random like
that it's like you know there is
technically context might be too heavy
of a word but it's not like there's no
context that that happened it's just
like okay I can envision that happening
in that instance it's not where is like
I
where is like something surreal they
just wouldn't be fluid at all it would
just be a string of stuff that doesn't
really tie in together and there's
really not like just loud noises loud
banging and just screaming at the TV and
so the one thing I said about this show
that I said was pretty cool you know
else I could be a my bright and colorful
and stuff like that yeah is that the
hard thing with really like random out
there humor is there relies a lot on
surprise and just being random and yeah
when you get into formula that it it's
hard to keep it going like even money
pipe I mean you like my place yeah I
mean we love my Python even we sort of
know like in the show like after white
you start to predict some of these jokes
like even though her all over again make
you think it's going this direction but
goes another you're like you cannot
predict what the hell is gonna happen we
have to stuff in these characters so I
mean and that is harder than it sounds
like it is difficult to do yeah because
you sit there and you're kind of like
whoa why wouldn't he suddenly have giant
legs and be walking through the
mountains with them writing on his back
sure and the universe that they've
established here by that can happen
suddenly has tall legs and he's walking
through the mountains
obviously if anything he probably should
have used that power to get them out of
that prison he probably could have
broken through if I know got really
small I got yeah what is that was it in
a block of ice just make himself bigger
in fact I was getting really worried
about it first time he was turning blue
like that can't be a good sign like he's
got to be dying so what does knowing
that every episode is pretty much like
or at least it seemed the first three
episodes are like this
should I keep doing this be long series
or should I just get out you know if you
if it goes along and you have more stuff
to say you know what I mean like it
would be it it'd be harder you know if
you're saying the same thing about every
single I don't know how the rest of
these episodes pretty much been like
this that's my it's like I'm going
through therapy it's like I'm talking
about this patient like whether or not I
should give up on this patient how many
episodes are there what 60 something
there's not
so I'm just trying to figure out it's
like should I actually keep doing this
and you go that way when it's over you
can do an episode on the Shyamalan
adaptation I love the way you say Shama
wand it's probably the right way but I
am alone I am a wad yeah it's like
that's how it's spelled it all says
shallow on but you know we're crackers
so I have no idea it's because I'm 180 I
am Allah so okay so I don't know if I'm
gonna try keep doing these yeah for
curiosity's sake go ahead just to see
you see where it got you saying like
just maybe just you'll see the slow
deteriorate deterioration I gotta find
new stuff for everyone so I mean thank
God I had a guest star in this once
filled it a little bit but yeah this
will be this will be interesting
oh I hope that I helped because lord
knows I now confused at least you've
seen a couple episodes like for all I
know I'm dreaming it's a similar feeling
that's the feeling this show has so yeah
I'll see you next time on adventure dug
therapy